لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[تصفيق]
ونعم الوكيل منكم يا سياسيين حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل منك يا احمد
وفرحان الله لا كسبكم ولسه انت بتتحاربوا
لسه انتو بتتحاربوا والله لا كسبكم لا في
الدنيا ولا في الاخرى نتلاقى ان شاء الله
يوم لا ينفع مال ولا بنون
الا بقلب سليم وين القلب سليم
سليم
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل منكم جميعا
بارك الله فيكم نقول لكم بارك الله فيكم
عطش اكثر من ثلاثه سنوات وانتم بتتفاوضوا
بتتفاوضوا
وتسودانيين ولا بتشبعوا السودانيين ولا
عمركم تعرفوا السودانيين
لا سياسيين نافعين لبرهان
الله يرحم السودان ويغفر له
مات السودان وانتهى السودان
لكن باذن الله تعالى لنا يوم معكم يوم لا
ينفع مال ولا بنون الا من اتى الله بقلب
[موسيقى]
سليم سنلتقي هناك
سنلتقي هناك
سنلتقي ذاك يوم القصاص ذاك يوم القصاص
سنلتقي ان شاء الله وليس انت بتحارب
الدماء هذه
وقفوها لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله لا حول
ولا قوه
جنبنا
جوعتونا عطشتونا
مرتتونا ولسه انتم بتتحاربوا وهذا هو هذا
هو
موت
[موسيقى]
السوق
ما تتعد